what are the principles whereby we can
navigate in the space of all possible
experience and experience better and
better lives and a better a better world
so today's Sunday's special featuring
Sam Harris the author of waking up and
the host of the waking up podcast will
begin in just a second first I want to
remind you that you're gonna die I'm
just gonna tell you right now it's gonna
happen and when that happens if you
don't have life insurance they're gonna
be really sorry 71% of people say they
need life insurance the answer is 100%
of people need life insurance and only
59% of people have coverage so at least
12% of people who want it are
procrastinating and sure normally
procrastinating is a bad thing but if
you're going to die it's an even worse
thing because while you are putting off
getting life insurance getting life
insurance was getting easier with policy
genius policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online you can
compare quotes in just five minutes when
it's that easy putting it off becomes a
lot harder you can compare quotes while
sitting on the couch watching TV or
while you're listening to this podcast
just try it policy genius has helped
over 4 million people shop for insurance
and placed over 20 billion dollars in
coverage they don't just make life
insurance easy they make disability
insurance and renter's insurance and
health insurance easy if you care about
it they can cover it so if you need life
insurance but you've been putting it off
because it's too confusing or you think
you don't have time checkout policy
genius the easy way to compare top
insurers find the best value for your
for you know sales pressure zero hassle
it's free policy genius calm when it's
this easy to compare life insurance why
put it off well speaking of life and
death Sam Harris yeah thank you so much
for stopping by sure and you know there
are certain weird things that happen in
your life where you think I'll never end
up being friends with that guy and then
you and I have ended up becoming pretty
friendly which is we're just really kind
of interesting so Sam Harris for those
who don't know is not only perhaps the
foremost atheist philosopher on planet
Earth he's also the host of the waking
up podcast he's a neuroscientist knows
run on neuroscientist and philosopher
they should check out his podcast is
just terrific and all of his books are
really worth the read I disagree with
them strenuously and they're really
intelligent really fun to read and he's
not trying to hide the ball so Sam
thanks so much for stopping by so let's
just jump right in with the fact that
you and I are now sitting together
because that in and of itself is a weird
thing what has happened in the country
that we're now part of this kind of
deviant conversation from the mainstream
that seems to be growing an audience
sighs well I you know
you and I are both part of this wing of
the media where we're having long-form
conversations that you're on podcast and
on you know YouTube videos where we're
reaching a surprisingly large audience
and because of the format we're not put
in these weird rhetorical boxes where we
have to struggle to make the other guy
look bad in the 45 seconds remaining you
know on CNN or wherever it is and so we
really can unpack a an argument and we
can search for the possibility of
convergence in real time together and so
that it's you know you might not notice
the difference if you're listening to
this in any you know 30-second bit of
conversation but over the course of an
hour or two hours you notice that you're
hearing a conversation that you're not
hearing elsewhere and so that I think
and you and I are we don't agree as you
say about about many things but we're
we're in the same media channel and
we're approaching these conversations in
a similar spirit of just being willing
to put our thoughts on the line and and
based on a principle of charity engaged
with the best version in our opponents I
think that's that's really important
because as you say when you're when
you're spend your life in cable news
it's always finding the worst version of
the argument bashing it with a club
until it's dead like a baby seal on the
ice but you know it's really interesting
so that the intellectual dark web which
is a coin turned by our friend Eric
Weinstein at your podcast where we were
doing a taping your podcast in San
Francisco and that of course is a
conversation between three people who
disagree on a wide variety of topics
what do you think sort of characterizes
this has become really controversial the
term itself there's been a lot of
backlash to even the idea that there is
an intellectual dark web does it exist
if so what are the sort of common
factors you think that unify the widely
disparate viewpoints therein well I
think it's what I just mentioned the
fact that these conversations are
happening in the dark with respect to
the mainstream media I don't think most
people at the New York Times or on CNN
understand how big your audience is or
how big Joe Rogan's audience is or my
audiences it's just the numbers would
surprise them and the fact that people
are listening with that level of
engagement would surprise them and yeah
ideology ideological commitment to side
or beliefs aside we're we're having
conversations you
that are not really yet on the radar of
the mainstream media and yet we have
analogous large audiences and again it's
it's a spirit of intellectual honesty
and adventure where we're not we're not
stuck simply trying to win points you
know may you and I will debate many
topics and you know I think I'm right
you think you're right and and it will
have the character of a debate but in
reality as as hard-hitting as any of
those exchanges could ever be
I'm not approaching it the way you turn
it over and look under the other side of
the rock and look at these viewpoints
all the way through and one of the
things that I think has happened it's
driven this group of people together is
the fact that the hard left has become
so ensconced in identity politics I know
that you obviously got into a very well
publicized exchange with as a recline at
Vox over this yeah and which I thought
he wasn't that fun I thought he was
deeply intellectually dishonest shocker
I thought it was deeply intellectually
dishonest and then his suggestion that
that you were saying identity politics
is bad isn't it in and of itself a form
of identity politics or what do you make
of this whole identity politics rising
tide and what do you think the backlash
do that's gonna be where is it coming
from well it's coming mostly from the
left its producing a counter effect on
the right which is you know white or
even white male identity politics you
know and so it's natural to see that
these two sides are amplifying one
another but on the Left it's much more
troubling for me because the left is the
space traditionally where you know
self-criticism and and wondering whether
or not you might be wrong is is just
what a paramount virtue right and so
your but what it would do that has
metastasizes it has metastasized in this
context to a kind of shattering of
epistemology where you know there's
there on some level there's no such
thing as truth there's just power right
we're just responding to differences in
power and all of this is anchored to
unchangeable characteristics like skin
color and and and sexual preference and
so it's just you are Wow I'd now often
describe this as just the the most
unhappy game of Dungeons and Dragons
that ever was invented because you have
to negotiate these power differentials
based on victimology
you know how many victimology points you
have in this game and you know as a
white privileged heterosexual you
basically have no points right so you're
you're you're not empowered to have a
credible opinion on any of the most
important topics of our time right
you're just you're either just part of
the problem with respect to all of these
variables and you're you're mansplaining
or you're you know cultural
appropriation or you're you know
weighting in here I mean this is what
happened with Ezra Klein at one point he
said you know we're two privileged white
Jewish guys who had who shouldn't be
talking about race at all right like
this is not something we can weigh in on
and then I want to change the topic to
anti-semitism it got no better for some
reason but it was it's a problem because
I mean I did clearly if we want to get
to a post-racial society if we want to
get to a society where human beings can
simply be identified as as human beings
the endgame can't be taking things like
race and gender and gender difference
and sexual orientation it immutably
seriously right this can't be just the
the in eradicable variables that had
define a person's position on important
topics for all time you know we're not
if we get to Mars and we're still
worried about skin color right you know
you know in a Martian colony we've done
something wrong and so I think we need
to reverse engineer what we think the
the the end state should be and clearly
identity politics is not the game we
should be playing a green I mean
obviously it's destroying the capacity
to even have these conversations cuz
there's no way to have a conversation
with someone who is spending the entire
time assessing whether your point of
view is even worth being taken seriously
as opposed to the rational nature of
what you're saying and and I think
that's that's one of the factors I think
that's unifying those of us we're having
these conversations I think another
factor that's that's unifying all of
this is a belief in in day
now I know that you you know obviously
are a deep believer in in data and
science I'm quite fond of data in
science myself although you would argue
obviously that is a religious person I'm
not fond quite enough of data in science
we'll get to some of that in a little
bit but it seems to me that one of the
one of the downsides of the identity
politics is the attempts to paint it
into a corner science as those Sciences
and outgrowth in particular culture and
is therefore irrelevant to general
swaths of people so in the Ezra Klein
interview for example when you suggested
that group differences in IQ exist and
you weren't even saying that those group
differences in IQ are attributable to
environment or genetics you were saying
we don't know the answer to that if I
don't want mischaracterize review and he
was immediately coming back with well
you can't say that and I'm not sure how
we're supposed to have conversations
when you legitimately can't cite data
before you even start having a
conversation yeah yeah and so you know
in defense of people who worry about
this kind of thing you know it's
obviously possible for data to be wrong
and then the conversation continues even
once you have data but what we should
all be anchored to is a good-faith
intellectually honest non smear
merchants approach to analyzing what we
think we know and why we think we know
it and those principles of rationality
and an empirical engagement with with
reality
simply are not susceptible to an
identity or even a political
interpretation I mean this is just this
is why reason is the only thing that
scales maybe if if I have a good enough
argument based on clear enough evidence
it should persuade you if you are you
being reasonable no matter what's your
background no matter who your parents
were no matter how you were mistreated
or not as a child you know if we build a
reasonable robot it should be persuaded
by the right arguments and the right
data so it rationality is is the mode of
argument where it doesn't depend who you
are
in order to in order to reach the right
answer I mean this is this is why
prototypical you know prototypically
reasonable or reason based topics are so
easily divorced from politics and things
mathematics right if people are anyone
who's going to argue that mathematics or
philosophical logic is is just a tool of
you know political ideology and
oppression it just knows nothing about
those topics but it's true that
virtually every other place that we
really care about facts and and you know
being right or wrong has that character
as it should be true ultimately of
journalism it's a you know either you
know Lee Harvey Oswald shot Kennedy or
he didn't right this is a it's a fact
about a human being holding a gun right
and we and we they get access to the
data or we don't so the fact that so
much of our discussion about what's
going on you know in terrestrial reality
is it's based on or so it was filtered
through the lens of people's political
commitments is it's just highly
dysfunctional
it's just not something to be maintained
we should be cutting through it wherever
we can so where do you think that the
United States is going because obviously
we've seen you know the rise of your
audience is enormous you have a huge
audience I think a lot of folks you
mentioned Joe Rogan has an enormous
audience Jordan Peterson obviously has a
very big audience a lot of these people
have a very big audience do you think
that the the rise of these new
conversations is are you optimistic or
pessimistic do you think that these new
conversations are going to turn into a
new sort of brand of politics that ends
up saving the country or are you
pessimistic and you think that ya
density politics machines that are now
operating at seemingly full blast on all
sides do you think that those end up
winning the day for the moment I don't
know yeah I really just the future is is
a big question mark for me because
because the present is fundamentally
surprising to me I didn't think we would
get Trump yeah there's almost nothing
and and getting Trump I didn't think we
would get the kind of reaction we see to
Trump and I could have predicted the
reaction on the left but it just amazes
me every day that he is as untouchable
based on his own missteps and and gaffes
and you know crazy utterances which is
the fact that nothing sticks to him it
surprises me every day so I don't quite
know how we got here I think we I mean I
think you and I will be fine right now
I'm very optimistic about our having
conversations like this and this
this channel in media would be having a
durable interest for people but whether
it will affect any real political change
in the near term I don't know because I
see that the left is fully capable of
playing a a what should be a fairly good
hand so badly is to just amplify you
know white populism and and trumpism for
you well beyond Trump's next four years
I just think it's there's there's no
mistake so idiotic that the left isn't
capable of it and that a and I'm you
know as you point out or as we'll
discover I'm you know I'm on the left on
virtually every relevant question except
except the ones we've been talking about
which is you know the virtues of
identity politics and victimology so
let's talk about your political
viewpoint a little bit so you say you're
on the left on a bunch of different
issues are you more on the Left socially
as far as being libertarian here has I
mean the truth is that you and I
probably agree on the government's role
in a lot of those particular areas
probably not on abortion but on same-sex
marriage for example you know I think we
probably agree the government should not
be involved in these sorts of decisions
yeah but as far as economics are you
also on the left ear are you more in
favor of redistribution ISM and on what
grounds well I I think the the
government I am a fan of libertarianism
up to a point I think the government
should only do what it can do best right
so answer that we know there's me
nothing but yep so then it then I think
the the the arguments about what markets
can do and and and not do it you know
that that's where it all gets hashed out
I think there are things that Marcus
just can't efficiently incentivize that
we really as a society want to
incentivize as quickly as possible so if
it said it transferred to a renewable
economy I think waiting around for the
market to get that perfectly right you
know for and you know which might only
happen if we just run out of oil you
know I think that's waiting too long
right so I think it's good so for
instance of people who and and also we
should recognize that the oil industry
is already subsidized right so it's so
if you got those subsidies out then
there would be a clear competition with
renewables and but I think it would be
rational for the government to
well pick a winner in that space not a
winner is it with respect to a specific
company but recognize that we want
there's certain things we want to
incentivize and one of them would be say
to get off of oil right forget about
global warming for a second just we want
clean air right so we wanted to
incentivize clean air the market isn't
necessarily the best way to do that
because if you are burning something
horrendous in your factory you can to
adequately compensate me for for the
smoke that you know blows over the fence
right there externalities obviously so I
think I think the externalities in many
cases are I think libertarians ignore
them or they think that that far too
blunt and instrument would correct for
them something like you know boycott you
know so if you're a massive polluter you
know and I don't like it I can organize
a boycott against you and in the
fullness of time that's going to do its
work but I think that's getting truer
and truer right I think the power of a
boycott now is with social media is is
is probably also as sharp as it can get
or or has ever been but yeah it's easy
to look back you know 20 years to see
just how ineffectual those efforts
might've been against big corporations
as you wonder whether whether the
government intervention ISM in the in
environmental issues particularly is in
fact you want an instrument given that
there are technological changes that
take place that radically changed the
nature of many of these industries so
for example I'm believer than the next
20 to 30 years very few people are
actually gonna commute to work I mean
the Internet has made it essentially
possible for you to work wherever you
want it's made it possible for me to
work wherever I want they're still
factories out there but that's a
shrinking percentage of the American
workforce I mean you're seeing major
retailers go out of business
specifically because people are sitting
home and and it may not be efficient for
companies to have all these trucks
running on the road as opposed to having
various forms of transportation so it
seems like a lot of the time on the gut
this is my worry isn't like a lot of the
time when the government tries to
intervene on behalf of you know curbing
those externalities it ends up doing a
lot more damage than it would if if we
would have been able to leave the market
in place in the market would come up
with solutions that would be better for
a broader spectrum of people but that
said I think that depends on the
immediacy of the threat and I think
that's really what people are talking
about when it comes
for example global warming how immediate
is that threat how many Utley do we have
to deal with it or any of the real
solutions that are being put on the
table capable of dealing with with the
level of threat that's being talked
about by the IPCC so I want to talk more
about that with you in just second first
we have to talk about protecting your
data so with all the recent news about
data hacks and breaches it's hard for me
not to worry about my digital privacy no
matter what you do online your mobile
carrier an Internet service provider
they track all of it every website you
visit all the emails you're sending it's
ridiculous so that's why I've taken back
my privacy I do use Express VPN and
these days I don't use the internet
without it expressvpn is the world's
leading VPN provider lets you securely
use the internet without being tracked
by anyone and expressvpn keeps my online
activity private and Annamma anonymous
while i browse or email or download or
stream it's great for streaming content
you can even use it to watch the World
Cup without a cable subscription if
you're into that sort of thing they're
easy to use app encrypts all of my
internet data and hides my IP address
which protects my connection which is
great for me you can express VPN cost
less than seven bucks a month and run
seamlessly in the background your
computer phone tablet every time you use
the internet without it you're putting
yourselves at risk so take back Internet
privacy today find out how you can get
three months free go to expressvpn comm
slash Ben that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
been for three months free with a
one-year package it is really easy to
set up takes legitimately only a couple
of minutes and then you just run in the
background your computer you never
notice it again but it's protecting you
does it Express VPN calm slash Ben to
learn more that's expressvpn comm slash
but ok so let's talk a little bit about
some of the kind of root issues that I
think people want us to get into which
is gonna be all the religion versus
atheism and and rationality and all the
deep stuff that is actually more fun to
talk about than politics in my view yeah
and I get the pleasure of talking about
it with you here because I don't usually
have the pleasure of talking about on a
daily basis when I'm covering politics
up since we get to do this let's do it
so let's talk about you know where you
think morality comes from so in the
religious view obviously there's certain
things that I believe are capable of
understanding by any sentient human
being so I don't believe that all human
beings in the absence of religion are
immoral people who go around murdering
their neighbors and raping their sisters
I think that and in fact this is pretty
well embedded in even Judaic philosophy
the idea that there is a sort of natural
law theology where you as just a normal
person know not to kill people and know
not to steal and notice that
courts of laws is what they call the
seven the Seven Commandments to Noah but
the idea is that anyone can basically
discover these things and there are
universals across culture about you're
not supposed to murder your brother but
the the biblical reading is that to
reach a more sophisticated level of
morality that leads to sort of right
based society we see here you at least
need the the catalyzing enzyme of a
judeo-christian religion in order in
order to get here that would I think be
the most rationalistic argument on
behalf of judeo-christian values but but
whereas here again here would be a
civilization that values individual
rights above the values of the
collective that says that that people
are to be treated cities the biblical
phrase as made in the image of God that
we should treat individuals is made in
the image of God that that does not
happen in the absence of a
judeo-christian value system that's
that's the religious argument so the and
and which although that is more of a
historical argument for that right and
that that's I'm saying some
rationalistic argument because the the
deeply religious argument be God said
says to do it right but that's not the
argument that I think is the most
compelling because that only works if
you believe in God and if you believe in
Revelation so that's not the argument
that I tend to make because I don't find
it intellectually convincing it's an
argument from Authority which of course
is not particularly convincing so I tend
to make the historical argument which is
that history brought us to that the
reason we are at this point in history
is because without that particular
catalyzing enzyme you don't get what you
have here which is why the West and
Western civilization crop up in a
judeo-christian system but don't crop up
in for example Islamic countries and
Islam has been around for a thousand
years so what do you number one would he
make of that argument and then I want to
get into so where do you think morality
comes from right well a few points I
have it one I I'm not convinced by that
historical argument I think you can you
can cherry-pick the data either way and
come up with with a different conclusion
and the even if I agreed with it it
wouldn't make the case I think you want
to make because they'd be an instance of
a what's called the genetic fallacy
which is if we even if we granted that
that our respect for individual rights
say came from a judeo-christian
tradition it doesn't mean that it can
only come from from there or that even
his best gotten from there and I was
say that it actually hasn't come
principally from there and there are
many way at least so for instance you
could say that that Christianity in
particular was responsible for in part
responsible for the fall of the Roman
Empire right so Christianity undermined
the notion that the the Roman Emperor
was a god you know it made it harder to
recruit true soldiers and they had to
farm it out to mercenaries and you know
it eroded you know what you might call
traditional Roman values and then you
know the Western Empire fell and you
know he will be ushered in the Dark Ages
and insofar as there was a reboot to
civilization at that point it was
largely the result of classical learning
and philosophical inside of antiquity
being preserved by of all people right
so I think it's you can you can have it
any way you want looking at history but
it just doesn't get you there in terms
of the the moral content and the and in
this case you know the political or
social content coming from the Bible or
any other religious texts so then why
then why here meaning like why in
judeo-christian civilization
civilization but not Islamic
civilization because you mentioned
rediscovery of Aristotle and and reason
Aristotle in 10th and 11th centuries was
really beginning you know in in the
Islamic world long before Aquinas really
repopulated it in the in the 13th and
14th centuries yeah well one I think
it's you know from my point of view it's
impossible to ignore the influence of
Islam
I mean Islam is its own ideology instead
of dogmatism that are inflexible and at
odds with the spirit of science in
fundamentally and despite the fact that
there was a brief period where there
seemed to be some you know happy
convergence between scientific and
mathematical insight and Islam for the
most part Islam has been hostile to you
know a real intellectual life and in a
way that Christianity was hostile even
when the scientific worldview was was
struggling to be borne in in you know
the 16th century in the 15th century the
what we have historically is a
real war of ideas that me that I've been
just - you just you can be crystallized
in the moment where you know Galileo was
shown the instruments of torture and put
under house arrest by people who refused
to look through his telescope right I
mean so that was the genius of religion
paired with the with the emerging genius
of science in that room I'll be fair I
mean Galileo was originally sponsored by
the church and so is Copernicus but the
but the there's a backlash from the
church to the stuff yes and the backlash
makes sense because there is a
intellectual progress on questions of
you know just you know how the cosmos is
organized or where it came from or how
life began you know all of these
questions are the scientific answers to
which are in zero-sum contests would the
doctrines found in the books now they're
it's true that there are religious
people and now even the Pope who have
relaxed their adherence to traditional
of to make room for something like
evolution right but it's still it is
still a problem I'm not a super new idea
I mean right Aquinas was talking about
this in the 13th century in 14th century
the idea that that if it was in science
and it was contradicted by the book then
you're miss reading the book I mean
that's that's that's pretty old idea but
that is just a vert science rather than
the book in Aquinas this case man
Aquinas thought heretics should be put
to death right his argument for that for
that for capital punishment for heresy
and Augustine made the same argument he
thought obviously the thought they
should be tortured right so that those
two great lights of the Catholic Church
gave us the Inquisition and gave us you
know more than a century I think it's
also fair to say that they were rather
instrumental in the development of
modern science so the the Dark Ages
first of all I think the Dark Ages are a
bit of an exaggeration in terms of the
Dark Ages themself had saw a massive a
massive growth in technology and
architecture for example I mean Gothic
cathedrals are built during the Dark
Ages especially but the scientific world
is well virtually every major university
in the Western world was sponsored by
the Catholic Church and I'm not I'm not
a great Catholic defender right I mean
but but virtually all these universities
were transferred by the Catholic Church
which saw continents between science and
religion as a reason to actually
investigate the natural world well no I
mean I think again I think that's
backwards I think the reality is
there was no I mean everything that was
good that was done anywhere at any time
prior to you know picture year was done
by some religious person there was just
nobody else to do the job right so you
could you could make the argument that
you know Catholics built every bridge in
Europe until the Protestants came around
and they built their half of the bridges
I mean so there was just no one else to
do the job and we're human beings who
want to pursue various ends many of
which require breakthroughs in learning
so you know is the engineering got born
in the religious context physics was you
know the first physicists were people
who were who were Christians who were
you know we have yeah you know as it's
often pointed out Newton spent half his
time worrying about Biblical prophecy
now I think that was a waste of an
objective waste of his time he also
spent a lot of his time worrying about
astrology right so you're trying to
alchemy yeah yeah yes and alchemy and an
alchemy insofar as there was anything to
it
apart from sort of kind of the internal
myth making that may be of use to some
people be edged into chemistry right so
like SOE
there's the there was often a real
science at the back of a lot of merely
mortal confusion where people were
trying to work things out you know I
would argue very much under the the
shadow of religious commitments that
they need not have had and we're not
actually serving their ultimate ends and
so and this is this for me is true in
the moral sphere as well because it's so
to take this is why the Bible in my view
can't be the real repository of our
moral wisdom in any sense because when
you go to read it you are forced to
ignore certain passages or reinterpret
them rather aggressively to conform to
what you now in the 21st century have
every reason to believe is good or a
direction worth going socially so you
know it is just an inconvenient fact
that slavery is endorsed in the Bible
it's clearly endorse in the Old
Testament and it's it's certainly not
repudiated in the new right and you know
Jesus told slaves to serve their masters
and serve their Christian masters
especially well so there's no place in
the Bible where you can get a
truly compelling case against slavery
because the creator of the universe
clearly expected slavery to be a
humanist except for abolitionists
finding enough inspiration in the bodies
they didn't XIV but they just they did
that despite what's in the Bible well
yeah I think I think that that is I mean
I I don't want to this this shouldn't
sound insulting because it's not meant
an insult I think that from a religious
point of view that's and that's that's a
simplistic reading of the Bible's role
in human affairs meaning that when any
written document is given to any group
of people it has to be given to people
in a way that they can understand it's
not that slavery was endorsed by the
Bible it's a slavery is Universal among
human civilization and so modern time
but it was no no that there were
certainly there are religions that have
different points of view on all these
questions right so it was possible in
the fifth century BC to have a take on
ethics with respect to something like
slavery or the killing of you know
combatants or non-combatants that was
quite a bit more modern and ethical and
and and civilized than was found that
was found in the Bible so it means you
take take em you might not like some of
their other commitments but take
something like Jainism right
Magina is I made Gandhi got his
non-violence from Jainism I'm a Jainism
is just in truth a religion of peace
unlike Islam which is a is you know the
word peace is a euphemism for the word
surrender their or submission
so it's you know it's possible for
people 2500 years ago to to wake up one
day and even write a book which suggests
don't harm anyone or anything even even
a cricket right well that's I mean
that's fine but the question is how many
conference does Jainism have meaning
that the point of if you're going to
give a book over it let's say that let's
pretend that you thought that God
existed and that you and that you were
he and it was and it was your job to
convey to a group of human beings what
you think morality should be
understanding that they're going to take
that and develop that because we do have
this gift of human reason that we use to
develop things and so there's a root
text and then it is developed over time
this is why I think Judaism is
particularly kind of unique in this
respect because that's been an ongoing
dialect
for literally thousands of years I mean
there's legitimately you know thousands
of pages of track dates of just people
arguing about these particular issues
you would say that the argument should
have started from the point of there was
no text for them to argue about and they
should have just argued from sort of a
priori reason maybe no I mean I respect
text but I think the principle of
Revelation is a problem but I just back
up for a second I think it's it's
certainly problematic for you as a Jew
to argue that the legitimacy or success
of a religion is best measured by the
number of adherents in year 2018
no but the poem at the point of Judaism
also is that the I mean it says in the
Bible itself that God is going to make
you know great peoples of all of
Abraham's sons for example and as
Maimonides put it in in the Jewish
belief the even the the growth of Islam
and Christianity which are obviously
based on a certain genetic route I think
Islam less so because there's an actual
rewriting of the Old Testament and the
New Testament not as much Maimonides
suggested that christianity had
basically been brought about as an
extension of judaism which is the
greatest christian is the greatest
converting religion in the history of
the world well but it seems strange to
count at the success of Critias success
in terms of numbers Jannetty in Islam
given that the basic principle that the
bottom line is the basic principles of
Judaism those have been embraced in a
way that the basic principles of Jainism
have not across time and they've shaped
civilizations in a way that is
significantly better than the principles
of Jainism have have shifted any number
of small people or small group of people
not run a small wrinkle obviously well
so again it's just the fact that you and
I could improve the Bible with very
little thought just by taking out so if
we just took out the worst passages that
have no possible redeemable content this
year or I would argue any other year
right the Bible has already improved
right so the fact that we could edit it
to anyone's advantage is a problem for
the idea that this is that was written
by an omniscient being and not to be
superseded by any human effort now or
generations from now and it's just not
the problem not just for the Bible it's
a problem for the Quran that and this
notion of Revelation is what gets us
there now if you're going to treat all
books as the product of
human minds you know brilliant or not
and every shelf in the bookstore or
library has the same status with respect
to their just the merely mortal
provenance of these ideas then it's fine
then you can do then you can pick and
choose the best ideas right and then you
can be you can be slavishly attached to
you know the Plato's Republic and just
let that can be your favorite book
but what revelation gets you is this
notion that no no this isn't just a book
right this is this is the product of
omniscience on some level and that ties
your hands intellectually because then
you are forced to make these acrobatic
contortions around passes it passages
which clearly have no good application
now and didn't even had a good have a
good application then and when you view
it from the other side when you think
about just mr. Howell just how good a
book would be if an omniscient being
being wrote it I mean that it's just
it's it's very easy to see what could be
in there that would still astonish us I
mean the or it would just be leave it's
very easy to see what could be in there
they would prove just based on the time
of its emergence that this couldn't have
been the product of merely human minds
and there's nothing like that in the
Bible
so it's responded says some of those
points I think that the there was a lot
there so I'm gonna try and kind of parse
it as we go I think that one of the
arguments that is made certainly in the
Talmud is the idea that human reason is
was generated in order to help reason
through the Bible basically that the
Bible is not just sure it is obey it but
it is also a constant conversation
between God and man in the sense that
there is a there is a active
conversation that goes into the
interpretation of these texts and so
what the Bible really is is an anchor
and the ship is anchored to the to the
anchor but there is still some slack in
the line meaning that it is it is not
that you are now tied to this anchor at
the bottom of the ocean there's still a
boat that's attached but human reason is
is designed in order so that you can
wobble through with this anchor attached
to you and if without the anchor you
ends up in a land of utopianism and I
the history of the 19th and 20th century
in the dusty Afghan view would be a good
example of how that happens and so the
construction of alternative morality
that is not based on any judeo-christian
notions can take you in any number of
horrible places that are significantly
worse in virtually every way than the
places that judeo-christian religion
brought you for for two thousand years
my argument is not that Judeo
Christianity itself the Judaism on its
own is everything that you need right as
an Orthodox Jew my argument is not that
my argue which if it were then I
wouldn't be out there caring about
science or about nature as you say and
people who are fundamentalists don't
care about any of those things I think
everything you need to be you need to
know is down in this particular book I
don't think I know how to fix my car
from from the Bible but what I do think
is that in the Strauss Ian view there's
a tension between Athens and Jerusalem
there's a tension between revelation and
reason and that without either one of
these things the reason without
revelation ends up in Utopia is of our
own creation that end up in really can't
end up in horrifying horrifying places
ranging from death camps to to gulags
and that revelation without reason ends
up in theocratic tyranny and so you do
need both of those in an interchange in
order to have something that means
something and the reason that
omniscience matters is because if there
is no belief in an objective level of
moral truth then everything becomes
subject to interpretation include up to
and including if you're intellectually
honest enough laws like murder because
maybe murder doesn't apply to people who
are outside my tribe maybe it doesn't
apply to people who are outside my
family or people I just want to kill for
my own benefit so this is where we get
into the alternative more acid this is
where I'm gonna ask you about your moral
basis so what so let me respond to some
of that sure there's a lot there so yeah
it's not gonna surprise you that I
disagree with you with that summary is
the fun part yeah so it'd mean to take
your anchor I think there is an anchor
or at least a foundation to everything
we can discover or value and it's human
conversation right and and and I think
the morality because I think revelation
that simply didn't happen right so it's
just human beings talking to one another
at any point in history thinking
internally I mean there have been
extraordinary people and they've had
extraordinary insights and they've
shared them and they've codified them in
books so the morality or pseudo morality
or barbaric morality that you find
various places in various texts was put
there by people right it's not that it
would came from some other source and
that we need to be anchored to it it is
a it is the record of a merely human
conversation that be the first to admit
has in various parts real value and real
you know wisdom in it and that's and
hence the reason why people are so
attached to some of it certainly but
it's just that's not unique for the
Bible that you can find that in among
Greek philosophers or you know various
places in antiquity and you can find it
in modern variants I mean you and I in
the prayer in the in one another's
presence here having a conversation that
gets recorded we can say something that
is highly relevant to the question of
you know how to live a good life and if
we were doing this 3,000 years ago and
it happened to get written down it would
be one of the lines that people would
think had been revealed if you know
they'll they lost track of what its
actual source was you know and so it's
it's people like ourselves that have
always done this work and so my my the
basic framework here is that all we have
is human conversation and all we can
appeal to are honest efforts to get at
the truth here and the choice for me is
between a 21st century conversation
where we avail ourselves of all of the
intellectual tools we can get in hand
and that includes whatever is good in
religion right so if there's something
that is in Ecclesiastes it is better put
there than anyplace else in the Canon of
all of human knowledge well then of
course we want to keep that right so but
how do you so how do you decide what is
the good because right now you're
essentially playing kotti under the tray
right you guys that you get to sit there
and say here's a good moral standard
here's a bad moral standard and you and
I will sit here in our conversation
we're better than a conversation a
thousand years ago this is a question
that I asked you actually last time we
spoke publicly and that and the question
is okay so if if that's the case you and
I tend to agree I would think on
probably 95% of our of our central
values about what it is that makes for a
good life right then I think that we we
both believe in individual freedoms I
think we both
the ability to live as you choose so
long as you're not hitting it anybody
else in the face as a general rule and I
think that we both agree on all of these
things and so what I asked you last time
is why do we agree on these things is it
because we just both happen to be super
unreasonable like we are just the most
reasonable people who ever lived and we
just happen to be here at this time and
why didn't people a thousand years ago
know this or is it you know back to my
original argument the fact that we grew
up probably ten miles from each other in
a city that was built in a country that
was built by people who believed all of
these things that came from a book half
of what you think is crap from you know
from a thousand years before Christ what
so I think the environment in which we
grew up insofar as this is a product of
culture is not mostly defined by the
judeo-christian tradition that it's
mostly defined by secular politics and
secular ethics that have some of which
are of a peace with those religions and
and other religions you know something
like the golden rule and the golden rule
predates Christianity certainly it is in
Leviticus I think and you love thy
neighbor as thyself Semitic isn't it
yeah and it open it it's not unique
there too rather there are Greek
philosophers I think Epictetus
articulated at some place the truth is
it predates our humanity on some basic
level you can see evidence of it in
monkeys right there's a there's an
expectation of fairness even in monkeys
right so this is a we're running a or
program that is morally relevant to us
that is riddled with bugs but that
predates our humanity and so we are so
largely what civilization is what gay
the the good parts of culture that will
lead to something that is that is
durable its level of civilization
largely correct for our merely hominid
merely evolved merely creaturely moral
intuitions so for instance that you'd be
like you and I have as a front and
center in our moral hardware a sense of
disgust right now and disgust is disgust
has roots but below anything that could
be considered moral it's just you know
you could smell something bad and you
feel like vomiting and
so but the truth is the in terms of the
evolution of the brain that the brain
doesn't evolve new modules that can do
fundamentally new things it has to
evolve capacities that are predicated on
the old hardware that was anchored to
things like you know the I'm gonna vomit
based on that smell right and much of
our moral thinking about the world is
discussed based or fear-based and it's
it gets applied to things like how you
feel about gay marriage say so you go
into it you know bible-thumping
fundamentals christian context where you
get you can find people who are just
adamant that gay marriage is wrong this
disgust circuitry is tuned up through
the lens of that social question and
that's a uiview conversation about
ethical truth and progress in ethical
space being more a matter of a reasoning
and unhooking are are reflexive in this
case discuss spaced intuitions about
from our sense of what is ultimately
good I mean there are things that you
and I might not be comfortable with the
first time we consider them that we can
get comfortable with by thinking it
through or imagining things from other
people the very least we think are
immoral and but still think that we have
no business in doing it yeah and
ultimately there are cases of kind of
moral dumbfounding where you would you
would have to admit this it's it's moral
in the sense that that you you can't
point to a victim right and yeah nothing
I talked about experiments like this let
somebody who's you know having sex with
the dead judge but I still discuss
disgust you like to take it out of the
moral sphere for a second if I told you
well I have I have Jeffrey Dahmer's
sweater you know it's been dry-cleaned
would you like to would you try it on
right now everyone recoils from that
right but it's not if you actually think
about it it's not something that it's
like oh there's kind of a magical
superstition intrude in there where you
read something that's been deposited in
the sweat or even though you know we we
you know 450 times right so it's and if
maybe a sweater is to charge but to take
something that where you there would be
absolutely no question that has DNA it's
not covered with his creepy guys DNA
it's it's something that you just in
order to recoil from it you are you are
thinking superstitiously right so you
can you can correct for those so you're
making an associate biological
explanation from where I like basically
Zinio Wilson explanation for the
evolution of morality no I bought so I
so to the contrary I think that there
are two very different ways to talk
about morality with respect to our
scientific understanding of ourselves
one is what you just referenced this
this biological evolutionary descriptive
story of how we got here you know why is
it that we're the sort of apes that feel
these sorts of ways about social
interactions say right and then and why
is is our moral thinking anchored to
those properties then there's a
completely separate question which is
the question that that interests me
morally which is given what we are and
given where we are right now what is
possible for us what how good could
human life be and what are the
principles of neurobiology and
everything else economics and sociology
and genetics anything that can be
brought to bear to change human
experience what are the principles
whereby we can navigate in this space of
all possible experience and experience
better and better lives and a better and
better world and so that's and that's
that is a very different question
because it it it presupposes I think
just on its phase that we have to mostly
most of our job is to fly the perch that
has been prepared to it but I think you
and I agree on this but I'm not sure why
okay so here are they I think the two
big questions that that I have one is
where does your concept of the good come
from and why is it universal and to you
just spelled out sort of your
differentiation from the the
sociobiological explanation for morality
that we evolved over time and that our
brains are evolved to perform certain
tasks and we sort of naturally came to a
level of morality but you're not
believing free well so what so when you
talk about
reason and you talk about you know the
importance of reason you and I fully
agree on this but my question is that as
a neuroscientist if we are just pure
material and we're just a bunch of
neurons firing outside of our own
control obviously because every cause
every effect has a cause if it's just
things happening you know and why should
we value reason it doesn't matter that
we value reason because we can't control
whether we value reason anyway are these
conversations kind of pointless because
or and then back to the first question
how exactly does reason play into the
good is that just a vague term for a
particular system of neurons that
convinces another particular set of
neurons right right so two questions
there what what is the foundation of
value and and morality specifically and
how does freewill or its absence
interact here so this is the foundation
for me is a and this is what this
connects to other questions where we are
intuitions probably divided I mean the
questions about you know what is the
meaning of life what is the purpose of
life those are questions that people ask
where religious people by and large feel
like you need an answer like there's
there's a there's a meaning shaped hole
in the world and we should fill it and I
given how I think view things think it's
the wrong question but what I see us as
having is an opportunity but we are in a
circumstance where based on the minds we
have there is a range of possible
experience and we don't and the horizon
goes in both directions to the very very
bad and the very very good and we don't
quite know how bad things can get but
based on what we do us yeah we know they
can get far worse than we ever want to
touch and so it is with the good we
don't know how good things can get and
yet we know the general direction where
we want to heads we we know that if the
world becomes more and more
characterized by love and joy and
creativity and compassion and insight
and fun and we know that's all that's
full suite of and we could we could you
can list that list those characteristics
as long as you want but there's a kind
of jewel with a thousand fast
that we want more of conscious entities
and there's a there's a far darker jewel
with as many facets that we want far
less of and this this spectrum admits of
seeming paradoxes which a you we could
both point to occasions where suffering
has led to something good right there's
a silver lining to certain kinds of pain
right or you you know if you want to
become a Navy SEAL and experience all
the empowerment that comes with that you
have to go through the hell of becoming
a Navy SEAL and that's a test and a
trial and and yet there's a massive
silver lining for people who come out
the other side of that so and yet if you
could sample a person's experience in
each moment through that ordeal it might
be indistinguishable from torture right
so but so that's just to say that the
frame around which we put certain
sensory experiences matters right if I
tell you that you know the pain in your
biceps is because you've been lifting
weights so much and you're making so
much progress you know you'll feel one
way about if I if I said to an identical
pain will you actually unfortunately
have arm cancer it's a very rare cancer
but you've got it right you'd be you
would feel that the suffering attendant
to that so but all this these are all
statements about what it's like to have
a human mind and and again these are
iView us as having a navigation problem
and the reason why I feel like there's a
foundational claim here that need not
even be argued for that is far more
defensible than a claim about Revelation
or anything else do you where you might
try to anchor morality is that all I
need is the acknowledgement that if we
if we imagine a universe where every
conscious mind suffers as much as it can
for as long as it can with nothing good
ever coming up but there's no silver
lining so we just have a we have a
perfect hell that has been designed for
every possible conscious mind right I
call that the worst possible misery for
everyone right that's bad if the word
bad is going to mean anything
it applies there right now if you're
gonna say it doesn't apply there if
you're gonna say well yeah that's kind
of bad but there are things that are
worse I don't know what you're talking
about
because I because by definition this is
the
worst possible misery for everyone right
so as long as you are going to
acknowledge that other states of the
universe are better than that right then
then you've given me my continuum of
better and worse they're making a very
saint anselm ontological argument here
about about the nature of bad and I'm
not sure that well no no I imagine the
worst I don't need to possibly imagine
then no no it's very different from that
because it's not it's not to say that
because that's clearly specious if I if
I said to you well there's a there's a
perfect turtle right I agree with you
I'm not depending on their logical
argument I'm making the argument you're
sort of making it nice it's not it may
sound that way but it's not so is it
there is it's so rudimentary exact think
I think that you're failing to define a
couple of terms meaning that so when you
say the worst possible suffering do you
mean physical suffering do you mean
mental suffering and the truth is any
combination that's the worst combined
suffering but people willingly it's all
mental it's all mental in the end that's
all a matter of consciousness in its
content right and in I think you're
you're I feel like you're playing a
little bit of a trick when you when you
sort of presuppose that we share a
common definition of suffering I think
there's certain things where we share
initially let's say we don't but so
let's say we have a helmet we can put on
and dial in every possible conscious
state for a human brain right yeah you
can wear the helmet I can wear the
helmet and we you know and we each tune
it to state you know X 551 right and I
say well how do you like that and we sew
one or one thing that is implicit here
although it's it's not a defeat or if
it's not so but I have an expectation
that you and I will converge yeah
perhaps not on every specific state as
our favorite or our least favorite but
there'll be there'll be whole families
of states there that you and I will
acknowledge well these are all fantastic
I you know maybe I'm not sure which I
like better than the other but this
we're like this is really good I'd like
to feel more of this and will converge
and based it's just based on the
similarity so how do you not end up if
you're pursuing the ultimate if there is
such a thing as the ultimate possible
good and this good is what you are how
do you not end up number one in sort of
the brave new world you're drugging
yourself the whole time for pleasure
good question
you know this does bring to mind and I
said by George Orwell that was the road
in 1940 about the rise of Nazism and
what he basically suggested was why is
it that everything is so good in the
West like everything is much better in
Britain than it is in Germany and yet
people are willingly joining up with
this monster to go and fight he said
because it turns out that a lot of
people don't want freedom a lot of
people don't want pleasure a lot of
people are willing to forego those
things in favor of a higher pursuit and
you see that now with literally billions
of people who I think that the the bush
line that every human soul yearns for
freedom I don't think that's true I
think there are a lot of people who
mystifying freedom or think that freedom
is something the freedom is not
otherwise they wouldn't normally convert
into these systems so I think that okay
but it is a little simple you know no
but none of this contradicts the picture
I'm painting it's just that all of these
things all of these differences among
people will have explanations and we we
don't yet have those explanations in
hand but so take the simplest case you
know you and I each put our hand on a
hot stove right now given our similarity
neurologically I would expect if the
stove is hot enough you and I will have
indistinguishable responses right and if
you don't if one of us doesn't have that
response there's something wrong with
our nervous system so but let's just say
we met somebody who had a different
different enough response that we even
couldn't converge on the question of you
know hot stoves are you know not worth
touching right you have so you know have
a masochist who likes a certain kind of
pain that you and I find intolerable now
there's an explanation for that
difference between us now it's a we
there might be and it might be an
explanation that we would have some
insight into maybe this person has
trained himself to feel this and as he
just gets this this massive you know
opiate rush you know it's it's like you
know in Lawrence of Arabia you know him
apparently it's a true story about him
but that's you know it's a you can train
yourself to feel a different way about
certain kinds of unpleasant classically
unpleasant stimuli but again all of this
fits in a complete picture that we don't
yet have about just why it is certain
minds are the way they are so that the
the macro question for me is given all
the minds as they are
where should we want to go both
individually and collectively and there
they're multiple there may be multiple
right answers to this it's not that
there's just one sort of life that is
the best possible life there's a range
of different lives that given a million
years to talk about it we might not be
able to distinguish which is better or
worse like you you know is is Chinese
food better than Thai food right it's
like like there's a range of differences
there which are which don't matter for
better or worse it's just different
right and and yet at the end of the day
if you really preferred one and I really
preferred the other we could find some
reason why that's the case I mean well
you might be a super taster of certain
tastes on your you know exactly but but
but then it's still coherent to ask
should we like if I if we could really
intrude in the brain and change our
intuitions about better and words right
if I could change your sense of the
rightness of certain actions or the
wrongness we could make this additional
quote we gotta ask this additional
question of whether that would be good
because that would be a new way of
navigating in the space and this brings
you to your brave new world question so
like if it's possible to let's say we
had a a cure for sadness right this is
this is an example I've used before
where you we have a pill that perfectly
cancels the feeling of grief say so
you're so at what point in the after the
death of a loved one would you want to
take this pill right and the answer
might be never and you would have a
reason why you know that was the case
but you could imagine someone who's just
so destroyed by the experience of grief
that they just can't get their life back
on track everyone in their life is
worried about them there you know on the
virtue of suicide at a certain point
you'd say well let's just give you this
pill and just see if we can you bring a
little daylight in there even if you
were against that you you write for
yourself right but presumably you
wouldn't want to take it thirty seconds
after your kid was run over by a bus you
know you just see this this this the
worst thing that's ever happened in your
life happened and then you just pop this
pill and you're you don't feel anything
you know one way or the other about it
right you're ready to go to Starbucks
right that would be that would be a
complete fragment
pation of who you are with respect to
the love you feel or felt for your child
right like what does loving your child
mean if upon immediately upon his or her
death you want to cancel your grief and
you feel great right so so that we don't
know what we did it would be hard to
find the right answer but and you know
this kind of thing is very likely coming
by the way right it's very likely we
will one day have a cure for grief right
and will fit have to figure out how to
use it and there will be wrong ways to
use it but I think what we want I think
the intuition that causes you to ask
this question about Aldous Huxley and
brave new world is that we we have a
we're right to want to be anchored to
reality in some sense and if we and if
we were ever faced with an opportunity
of just uploading ourselves into a
simulation where just the world is a
video game and nothing nothing is real
right so like that our states of
happiness are totally divorced from the
reality of our lives right and our
actual relationships and the conscious
experience of other people that would be
a bad thing right and yet we could
imagine a circumstance of maximizing
pleasure they in a way that's divorced
from reality and that's an interesting
argument to have ethically because I
think that there's I think our
intuitions about that could change to
some degree and I think that there are
ways in which we are already in
something very much like a simulation
that's not like that to talk about what
what is real in this context is
interesting but I share I share your
bias here I share the sense that their
versions of brave you know pure pleasure
brave new world futures where everyone's
a heroin addict perfectly medicated
that's not good right and and I think
but I think you can you can adjudicate
that based on other possible experiences
in the landscape of all possible
experiences that are clearly better and
you would make an argument based on
evaluate in those experiences okay so
well this is one of those episodes where
it's just I'm gonna be devastated that
we don't have a second hour to actually
go into all these issues forward because
we basically scratched the surface on
all of this but sort of final parting
question because we didn't even get into
reality or free will exactly a couple
places where I'm sure we have more
disagreements but I have a very short
answer yeah that'd be perfect okay so
don't worry so rationality I think I
said I might have said this to you on
stage
at our event right rationality is not a
the successful moments of reasoning are
not examples where freedom of will is
even tempting to ascribe and so it's
it's if I give you an argument you have
if you strongly believe one thing and I
give you an argument that persuades you
that just knocks down the row of
dominoes in your mind it leads you to
threat no I understand it's a
naturalistic response to a reasonable
argument that without any control over
that well you you don't have any control
over over any moment where you finally
see the light so I give you a chain of
reasoning and it works you would that
that's a moment where you are changed by
something extrinsic to your own volition
right my basic response to that is yes
and no because you see people who
clearly resist the impact of a
reasonable argument well themselves
that's what the resistance is what it is
to be unreasonable or to be under this
way of wishful thinking or comprehension
the bottom line is that from my
perspective that is somebody if the idea
is that reason is basically just
eliciting a particular response then
people have the capacity to override
their ability to listen to reason
but so if you're gonna describe that to
free will that's that's a different
thing to ascribe but that again I would
I wouldn't you don't need freewill to
explain that but that's that is take the
reasoning piece if I give you the
quintessential moment of it I give you a
column of numbers to add up right you
have zero degrees of freedom if you're
going to actually be doing arithmetic so
then the question is to the final
question here because we because and
four we're gonna have to have you in for
like a four hour session here in Josh
moves but it's but is the argument in
favor of reason a moral reason is good
argument or is the argument a
utilitarian reason is useful argument or
is it both because I can imagine a lot
of ways to convince people with things
that don't involve me making arguments
to them and that historically have been
used to great success with horrible
horrific human carnage obviously well
you're not necessarily convincing them
in that case you're just forcing them
poison
yeah that's right although I would say
that you can indoctrinate fully millions
of people interpret it you would think
this to write a misery that it's
possible to indoctrinate people not
using reason into fully form belief
systems your honor so is it so when you
make the argument for reason are you
saying the reason is morally better and
if so why is reason morally better than
example the appeal of passion which has
obviously motivated millions of billions
of people over time right well I I don't
think they're separable as many people
think I think you can't reason and
there's neurological evidence to back
this up and the Antonio Damasio did this
work decades ago where if you have
certain neurological injuries in the
right or below middle prefrontal cortex
you can't you can't be moved by the
products of your quote reasoning because
I've been reason has to be anchored to
emotion in a very direct way and you can
actually feel this in yourself so if I
say something it starts to sound like
bull to you right that feeling of doubt
you know the feeling that you have
detected errors in my chain of reasoning
that feels like something that is an
emotion right and if you couldn't feel
that you know that was all just cold and
calculating and just as I says he paths
you know can't reason their way to
virtually anything well they can really
well or we can't can reason their way to
everything they can they can they can
reason fine unfortunately they just
don't care about other people's
experience so they're they're very
they're they're very manipulative in
ways that you and I wouldn't the reason
itself doesn't arrive at a moral answer
in any case so so for me reason is the
only thing that again as we talked about
at the top of this it's the only thing
that that takes us out of who we are and
scales to some universal point of view
it's it's it's not it's you're not
reasoning if you're actually reasoning
what you're arriving at is not just true
for you it's true for anyone who could
be in it's true from essentially above
on any given topic you know it does
offer the view from above or the view
from any possible perspective or at
least it takes in the into account the
effect of perspective you know so it's
like if you know again reason is and
scientific rationality generally is the
thing that explains why you know if
you're color blind you don't see colors
the way I do right and that's it but
it's not that we can't get at what's
actually real we can we could because we
can explain divergences of opinion it's
and and otherwise you just have those
divergences well we are definitely gonna
have to have you back for a much longer
conversation it's really a pleasure to
have you here thank you so much for
folks who haven't who don't know Sam's
podcast I'm sure you do
it's waking up Sam Sann podcasters
waking up podcast and is his most recent
book is waking up your so so check that
out Sam thanks so much for stopping by
really
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah of era and title graphics by
Cynthia and Gullu ben shapiro shows
sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]
you